Allah Allah ben Semra Çetinkaya 1962
yılında İstanbul'da doğdum Ben 40
günlükken Anne babam Almanya'ya çalışmak
için gidiyorlar babam kaynak şefliği
yapıyor Annem ise vinç operatörü on
yaşına kadar beni Anneannem büyüttü
Anneannemde müteahhiti aynı zamanda
Belediye Hizmet azalsaydı Hatta büyük
teyzemde Cup zamandı Yani anlayacağınız
Ben genleri güçlü kadınlardan olan bir
10 yaşında Almanya'ya gittim orada Okulu
Bitirdim gymnasıen Bitirdim 17 yaşında
babam orada bir hasta evlenmeyin diye
bizi Türkiye gönderdim Ben 18 yaşında
Ben de evlendim 30 yaşında boşandım
Boşandıktan sonra iş kurdum sigorta
cendeli açtım İstanbul İyi acentelerden
de bir tanesiydim geçtim güzeldim
sağlıklıyım benim başıma bir şey gelmez
diye düşünenlerden değilim ki kelime
hayat sigortası bile yaptırmıştım iş
arkadaşımla birlikte iş seyahatini
arabayla çıktık yolda bizi trafik polisi
durdurdu Adana'ya gittiğimiz bir
yolculuktu o Hatta ben şuraya kadar
hatırlıyorum gündüz yapılmış olan bir
kazaydı bağdaş kurmuştu kuruyemiş uzun
sohbet ederek ten yola devam ediyorduk
Silo trafik polisi durdurdu emniyet
kemeri takılı olmadı şimdi ceza yedik
ceza ödedik amaç kemeri takmadan devam
ettik Hatta o da çok sıcaktı oruç de
insandı Emniyet kemerinin dağılması bizi
bunalttı işler halde ya da bilinçli
insanlar olmadığımız için kemeri takmak
yola devam ettik diyorum devamında
bu konuda ölüm virajı uçurumdan aşağı
Yuvarlanmış hız buraya kadar benim hatam
vardı Emek kime takmıştım Ama son şansım
olan ilk yardım maalesef dilsiz kişiler
tarafından yapılmış eminim ki Onlar da
iyiler de Fakat benim boynumu
sabitlemeden sırtımı sabitlemeden Hava
da çok sıcak olduğu için savursa çıktı
zaten Oradan Bey çekleri çıkartmışlar
İşte bu sebepten dolayı buydu da çok
ağır hasar almış ama en önemlisi omurgam
kırılmış yanlış He kağıdından dolayı
çekildiğim içinde kırık omurga omuriliği
mi kesmiş toka 4 delikleri göğüs
seviyesini altından sonra omütf elsim
yani bacakta mis edemiyorum hareket
edemiyorum ilk tedavi Adana dolmuş Fakat
sadece orada kırılan kemiklerin Umurlu
ile batan kemiklerimi temizlemiş ler
omurgamı kaynaması için sabitlenen
platin bulamamışlar ve ameliyatında
sonlandırmış lar İstanbul'a com
de tekrar özel bir hastaneye yattım o da
platin takıldı uzun bir yoğun bakım
süreci yoğun bakımda Tamam zaman soruyor
muşum ki ben hiç hatırlamıyorum Ne oldu
benim bacaklarım kestiniz mi mi
hissettim niye görevi niye kalkamıyorum
ben dediğimde sen bir kaza geçirdim
merak etme bacakların 40 daha sonra alçı
alacağız denmiş yoğun bakım süreci
bitmiş odama geçtiğimde dr.big
geldiğinde Sorduğum soru Hocam ben ne
zaman kalkacağım ne zaman göreceğim
başlattım ne zaman aç alacaksınız diye
sorduğumda Semra dedi Sen bir kaza
geçirdim Evet hocam kazada omurgan
kırılmış E hocam içinden geçen omurilik
kopmuş Semra büyük bir ihtimalle yanlış
ihtiyacı masasını olmuş dediğin değil
hocam Nasıl yani ben abi Gümüş ekmeğim
yani perşembe kde yemek bilmiyorum Evet
de Sema senin yürüme şansı yüzde bir
Bu pek dedim Ayhan Ayhan oldu o da öldü
Allah'ım hayatım 600 sordu Neden ben ben
ne yaptım Ne suç işledim dışarıda bu
kadar ararsın uğursuzu yalancısı
yürürken neden ben diye sorguladın her
şeyi o mesajın yaşamı çok zor
ameliyatları çok zor tedavi çok zor
annem babam kardeşlerim yakın ailem
çevrem maddi-manevi yanında oldular ama
paramız bitti ben de hastaneden taburcu
olmak zorunda kaldım O koşarak indim
basamaklardan Ayla sobamı kucağında
yukarı çıktım ben gelmeden Annem
yatağımı hazırlamış gelenim gidenim çok
olacağı için beni babam kucağına yatağa
yatırdı sonuç evrenin baktım altı
gülünmeyecek diyorum ben diye içimden
çok büyük üzüntüler geçtim Kafesteki
kuşun hareket ediyor çocuklarım hareket
ediyor annem babam dünya hareket ediyor
ha
bir tanem bir tek ben ki duvarımdaki
saat hatta sadece şöyle baktığımız zaman
mutlu bile oldum hareket edemiyor ya
biraz bencillik daha insanlar demek Ama
Ona kıyamadım ertesi gün planladım vee o
kaldığı yerden devam etti Ben kendim
aylardır sandalyede almadım çünkü komik
felcine olduğunu bilmiyordum hayatım ilk
defa Kerim'de yaşadım Kerim'de öğrenmeye
çalıştım çünkü kazandı felç hocam
bilemiyorum ya insan sakatlanır Belki
Hani ayağa bacağı kopan ya da ölür diye
biliyordum Oysa omik first olmak çok zor
bir şey hayatımıza kazandığınız her şeyi
kaybede biliyorsunuz en üst seviyeden en
az seviyeye düşe biliyorsunuz İşte ben
öyle bir zamanda evime geldiğimde artık
gelen gidenlerin de azalmaya başladı
Semra ne zaman bir şey lazım olursa ara
beni diyenler oldu ben Kimseyi aramadım
Çünkü benim her an bence en iyisi
ihtiyacım var ya tam da dönemiyor
var yani düşünün kendinize her iki
dediğimizi düşün Böyle bir süreç dedim
bu zorlu Annem dedi ki Semra bir
teklifte bulundu bana Semra gel kızım
eşyaları Saat iki çocuğunu alıyor ya Gel
yanıma biz sana bakarız dedi Düşündüm
taşındım
o ilk defa neme karşı geldim anne dedim
izin ver Ben bu hayatta tek başıma
yaşayacağım
ama annem Bunu duyunca çok şaşırdı
üzüldü mü İnanamadı ağladı ve çekti
gitti annende gidince ben 32 yaşında
kızım dokuz yaşında oğlum 13 yaşında bir
biz bu zor hayatı kendi başımıza
başarmaya çalışırken karnımız acıkıyor
evimde benim daha önce iyi çalıştığım
için para kazandım için kadınım vardı
Marşı veremeyeceği o da çıktı be
karşımıza çıkıyor da kızım getir
tencereyi getiren gibi sofra bezi gitti
yatağın içine Ben soğanın rendeledim
Hadi kızım şimdi onu sen bir şey kavur
bakalım Türkçe sesini duyuyorum ama
dikkat saçını yanmasın kızım uyanmasın
yapmadıkları zaman azarlıyor dum oğlum
sonunda boşaltıldı bir giydirmeye
çalışıyordu Biz ama annem babam oldular
Hatta ben onları çok haksızlık da yaptım
çünkü yapamadıkları zaman elimde ne
varsa attım onlara yastık attım işte
İlacım
Bu bir şey attım yapamıyorsun beceri ve
su dediğimde kızım karşıma çıktı ve anne
dedi sen işte Anneni ameliyathanede
bekledin mi Ben kardeşimle kaysefesi
ameliyathane bekleyin biliyor musun
dediğimde bir Tokat yedim Onlar daha çok
ufacıktı bıo onlardan Doktor olmasını
bekledim tamirci olmasını bekledim Aşık
olmasın bekledim o sonlar çocuktu Ben
şimdi seçim yapmalıydım ve yaşamı seçme
Leydim önce benim çocuklarım benim için
değerliydi Çünkü ben eşimden daha önce
Allah'tan daha önce boş almıştım Çünkü o
nüfel soğuduktan sonra çok fazla boşanma
hikayeleri var O iki tane çocuğumun
eksik de olsa mükemmel olmasanda annesi
olmak zorundaydım okullarında çok aktif
olarak çalışan Ben artık telefonlara
çocuksa bu takip etmeye başladım Hatta
Oğlum bugün beni burada izliyor ağabey
bir yerlerde Bundan zor söylemişlerdi ve
bu şekilde bizim onun
bu bulunca dil tedavi olmamız lazım
Fizik Tedavi olmamız içinde kaslarımızı
güçlü olması lazım bir devlet hastanesi
yaptığımda hemşirem bana dedi ki Semra
Hanım beyin cerrahı Cengiz Bey size
odasında bekliyor bu akşam nöbetçi a
beyin cerrahı demek ben Yürüyeceğim diye
çok heveslendim ve gittiğimde hikayemi
öğrendi dik Semra Burada o kadar çok
hasta insan var ki o büyük sayı solmuş
trafik kazası silahla yaralanma
yüksekten düşme iş kazası denize
balıklama atlama toplum bu konuda
bilinçsiz gel ben size eğitim vereyim
hikaye duyduktan sonra senin gibi hikaye
Sonra insanlar bana bu lütfen Ben 6 ay
boyunca ilk yardım konusunda eğitim
veririm unuttum konusunda eğitim veririm
bir kağıdın bilmiyorsan dokunmayı toplum
öğretmemiz lazım Projenin bir ayağı Bu
bir araya ise sizin gibi de tamam
dezavantajlı yaşayan insanları toplumu
eğitmek e
O bizim çalışma boğuldu Anaokulundan
üniversiteye kadar bütün topluma o mu
Bir Omurga nedir Onu yüz felci nedir
Bunları öğrettim ve hala da bu çalışmalı
çok severek yapıyorum ben bu süreci
Yaşarken bir telefon geldi bu iki adım
çalışma içinde var olmuşken bir elbise
giymiş oldum çünkü daha önce Semra
Çetinkaya'nın randevu alıp gelinirken
bir anda Tekerlekli sandalyeyi de
yaşadığım da yok sayıldım Yani insanlar
benim sandalye mi görüyordu Benimki mi
görmüyordu evime geldiğinde bir telefon
geldi geldi doktor olduğunu omik felçler
Derneği'ni kurmak istediğini
söylediğinde çok heyecanlandım Hayal ol
burada yürüyebilirim acaba benim için
bir çare buldular de düşündüm de şu anda
gördüğünüz Dernek kurucu başkanımız
Ramazan Bey onu da çok teşekkür ederim
bana çok güzel yoldaşlık ettiği için
Dernek koyduğumuzda iki gittim eve ilk
defa
çok komik felcini iomi felci gibi
görmeyen sandalyesi yaşamı Kur'an
insanlarla gördüm çünkü en yani Ömür
Face'i Ben limon aralarında bir hatta
yak yürümediğim için ayakkabı bile
giymiyorum Başak tam yok sevmiştim bir
baktım onlar tekerlekli sandalyesinde
konuşuyorlar gülüyorlar projeleri var
herkes senesini söyle 18 sebili on
sevgili 15 Sen duyunca Şok geçirdim
Allah'ım dedim adam da ölmemiş 18
senedir yaşıyorlar Şu anda ben
karşınızdayım besle komik versin o
yüzden yine felçlere söylemiyor mu Çünkü
hep yürümek gibi düşünüyoruz biz her
şeyi belki kimseye muhtaç olmak adına
şimdi bu sefer soğuduktan sonra ben
sigorta kentini kurmaya çalıştım fakat
Batur ülkemizi erişim ulaşılamadığı
sigorta janti kuramadım O yüzden Burada
gördüğünüz iş Altına gelin çalışmayı çok
seven bir insandım ama dernekte Gönül
çalış
o kimse ve gönüllü fatura ödemeli kimse
bana gönüllü olarak da Sema ne ihtiyacım
var diyemedi Çünkü derneklerde
bağışlarla Ayakta duruyor o yüzden ben
de alışveriş merkezine işe başladım
danışma şefi olarak başladım Hatta
altında 5-6 arkadaşım vardı danışma şefi
gördük masa başında kampanyaları takip
ediyor Mustafa yapıyor kiralama müşteri
ilişkileri gibi şeyler yap masa başında
Siz ne yapıyorsunuz Ben de bunu
yapabilirim Yeter bu konuda eğitimli
olayım ben çalışırken Tabii bir taraftan
şeyli çalışıyor Barbie çalışıyordum
işimden Derneği koşuyordum belki işimi
bitirirsem işyerime koşuyordum evime
koşuyordum Bir taraftan da Anne olmak
istiyorum diye bahsettim ya size İlksan
dayım geldiğinde mesela mutfağıma girdim
ve ben düzenli takibi bir kadınım O
yüzden insanlar yorarım böyle işte şunu
kaldır bunu kaldı bak o yumruk olmuş
falan giy
Evet Ee her şey kabul etmek zorunda
kaldım ya Sadece anne ya da insan bir
kadın olaraktan düzen soslu olur gibi
düşündüm ama ilksanda oturduğumda
mutfağıma girdiğinde bir görseniz bu
Mutfağın hali sanki adına fay hattı
geçmiş gibi Karman çorman Herkes bir şey
bırakmış bulaşıklar daha gibi bulaştırma
yıkama yeltendim ama ayakta alışkın hale
getirdiğimiz için otururken çok şaşırdım
elimi uzattım lavabo uzanamadığı Piruz
anlamadım süngeri mu zam adım Ben bir
çare bulmayı ne yaptım ne yaptım ama
lafın altında dolap kapağı var İkisini
açtım sandalye içine girdim bilim attım
lavabomu açtım süngerimi aldım döktüm
yıkadım yıkadım yıkadım dünyanın bütün
buluşun yıkayabilirim Oysa biliyorsunuz
bir bak bir bardak bile gördüğümüz zaman
ya bulaşık de deriz ya onu yapamadığımız
ilk başarılı bir şey buldu ve dünyanın
en
Ya ben beğendim Teşekkür ederim Neler
başardım dediğim gibi o Face'leri olan
arkadaşlarıma yoldaşlık yapmayı çok
sevdim hayatın ne kazandıysa onlara
paylaşmayı Biraz önce mutfakta anlattım
ya O kadar çok engelli arkadaşımız var
ki yatağından sandalye s kalkmıyor kin
tamamen değersiz ve yok sayıyor O
insanları 81'i dokundum bana arayan beni
ulaşan herkese zamanım ayırdım Telefonla
konuştuğumu sağlık sorunlarını çözmeye
çalıştım mutfakta onları eğitim verdim
Hatta bir tane Nursel ablamız var da
kulakları çınlasın ve senin komik
felsefemiz ilk defa ben böyle heyecanlı
heyecanlı anlatınca ilk defa mutfağına
girmiş yemek yapmış Semra de senin
sayende Ben kadınlığımı tekrar yaşadım
bu Beni o kadar çok mutlu etti ki mesela
ne yaptım engelsizsiniz projesinde yer
aldım
bu ve seyahatlerinde idolar bu motorlar
motorlar ulaşamaz birçok nokta var
Asansör koymuşlar öyle bir sonra bol
koyuyorlar ben seni ulaşamıyorum mesela
engel hastane projesinde yer aldım 80
birden dediğim gibi hasta
arkadaşlarımızın bilimsel çalışmalarına
göre aldım yapma kadar çok şey var ki
kötü kötü hikaye anlattı mızı ben seni
sonra şunu söylemek istiyorum Daha önce
ben bir 80 böyle bir kadındım ama ya da
yaşıyordum oradaki farketmedim
İstanbul'a gelme kompleks haline
getirdim bu durumumuzda mı Nasıl
indireceğim iki küçük diyeceğim
düşünüyordum Herkes bana Mete derken
Semra Maşallah ya ne kadar güzel boyun
var bize manken olsak senin gibi olurduk
dediklerinde oturup ağladım Allah'ım
gelmiş dizlerinden kesek bir o bir
elinde boyuna kadın olsam derdim sen
daha oturdum ve mevzuya istedim belli
böyle kadın olmuş lütfen evine güzel
şeyler
Ama bunlar çok değerli bir şey bana son
soracak olursanız belki Semra bu hayat
sana ne öğretti daha önce altını
çizdiğim şeylere şimdi Üstün çizimi
öğretti çok saçma şeyler Ağlamış üzülür
müsünüz Oysa ben çok da önemi bişeyler
varmış hayatta öyle Şanlı unutmayın Ben
engelliyim açtım
var ya siz ne